dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I here today the
game we'll be talking about is the sixth
player No Limit Hold'em poker which is
one of the more popular poker variants
out there and the goal of this project
was to build the poker AI that never
played against a human before and learns
entirely through self play and is able
to defeat professional human players
during these tests two of the players
that were tested against our former
World Series of Poker Main Event winners
and of course before you ask yes in a
moment
we'll look at an example hand that shows
how the AI traps a human player poker is
very difficult to learn for AI bots
because it is a game of imperfect
information for instance chess is a game
of perfect information where we see all
the pieces and can make a good decision
if we analyze the situation well however
not so much in poker because only at the
very end of the hand do the players show
what they have this makes it extremely
difficult to train an AI to do well and
now let's have a look at the promised
example hand here we talked about
imperfect information just a moment ago
so I'll note that all the cards are
shown face-up for us to make the
analysis of this hand easier of course
this is not how the hands were played
you see the AI up here marked with p2
sitting pretty with a jack and a queen
and before the flop happens which is
when the first three cards are revealed
only one human player seems to be
interested in this hand during the flop
the AI pared its Queen and has a jack as
a kicker which if played well is going
to be disastrous for the human player so
why is that you see the human player
also paired their Queen but has a weaker
kicker and will therefore lose to the a
ice hand in this case this player thinks
they have a strong hand and we'll get
lots of value out of it only to find out
that they will be the one milked by the
AI so how exactly does that happen well
look here carefully the bot shows
weakness by checking here to which the
players answer is a small race the bots
again shows weakness by just calling the
race and checking again on the turn
essentially saying I am weak don't hurt
me
by the time we get to the river the AI
again appears weak to the human player
who now tries to make the bot with a
mid-size race and the AI recognizes that
now is the time to pounce the confused
player calls the bat and gets milked for
almost all their money an excellent slow
play from the AI now note that one hand
is difficult to evaluate in isolation
this was a great hand indeed but we need
to look at entire games to get a better
grasp of the capabilities of this AI so
if we look at the dollar equivalent
value of the chips in the game the AI
was able to win $1,000 from these five
professional poker players every hour it
also uses very little resources can be
trained in the cloud for only several
hundred dollars and exceeds human level
performance within only 20 hours what
you see here is a decision tree that
explains how the algorithm figures out
whether to check or bet and as you see
here this tree is traversed in a
depth-first way so first it descends
deep into one possible decision and
later as more options are being enrolled
and evaluated the probability of these
choices are updated above in simpler
words first the AI seems somewhat sure
that checking would be the good choice
here but after carefully evaluating both
decisions it is able to further
reinforce this choice one of the
professional players noted that the bot
is a much more efficient buffer than a
human and always puts on a lot of
pressure now note that this is also a
general learning technique and is not
tailored specifically for poker and as a
result the authors of the paper noted
that they will also try it on other
imperfect information games in the
future what a time to be alive this
episode has been supported by weights
and biases weights and biases provides
tools to track your experiments in your
deep learning projects it can save you a
ton of time and money in these projects
and is being used by open AI taura
research Stanford and Berkeley it is
really easy to use in fact
this blog post describes how you can
visualize your chaos models with only
one line of code when you run this model
it will also start saving relevant
metrics for you and here you can see the
visualization of dimension model and
these metrics as well that's it you're
done it can do a lot more than this of
course and you know what the best part
is the best part is that it's free and
will always be free for academics and
open-source projects make sure to visit
them through Wendy b.com slash papers
waa and DB dot-com slash papers or just
click the link in the video description
and sign up for a free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time